if I were to ask you what a werewolf is
it is likely that those of you who have
never read the stories or seen the
movies would still be able to tell me
the basics it's someone who can turn
into a wolf
something about a full moon and if you
run into a silver bullet you're dead
right not exactly a fountain of
knowledge but these are the things that
we all know today we're going to examine
why werewolves have become such an
iconic figure in popular culture where
they originated from and why it's come
to this you don't live in the world you
think you do
no that wasn't porn those are just some
modern-day werewolves to understand the
origins of werewolves we have to first
off deep into their rich history though
it is unclear where and when the legend
of the werewolf originated from there
are some scholars who believe they first
appeared in the epic of gilgamesh when a
Gilgamesh himself jilted a potential
lover because she had turned a previous
mate into a wolf werewolves also made an
appearance in Greek mythology with the
legend of like hoenn like owen did not
believe that Zeus was an all-seeing God
and decided that he would test him by
sacrificing one of his sons and serving
him to Zeus for dinner
not exactly father of the year but like
Owen had over fifty children and it's
likely he didn't care much for them upon
discovering the tainted dish Zeus was
furious of like Owen and turned him and
his sons into wolves the concept of men
becoming wolves or animals has existed
for centuries in the 13th century
Icelandic work the vasana saga men were
shown wearing the skin of wolves in
order to fight like them the Norse
berserkers charged into battle wearing
nothing but the pelts of animals as they
believe this emboldened them there have
been some experts who claimed that their
behavior may have been caused by a plant
called bog myrtle
one of the main spices used in
Scandinavian alcoholic beverages the
berserk Warriors being drunk would
explain why they were running around
almost butt-naked an animal first
screaming oh maybe that was just a
regular Friday night for a Viking
most of us have heard of the witch hunts
that took place in the 16th century but
the less well known werewolf hunts took
place in the same period interrogations
of werewolves often involve peeling back
a person's skin to see what was
underneath as it was a common belief
that werewolves turned their skin
inside-out on in human form the 16th
century saw a rise of people claiming to
be werewolves when committing murders
and other heinous crimes
in 1589 in the sleepy town of bed burg
just outside of Cologne Germany a man
named Peter Stumpf was executed for
cannibalism responsible for over a dozen
murders Stumpf claimed that he was in
possession of a belt that allowed him to
turn into a wolf so how does one become
a werewolf well he 4-game by the
earliest literature then people were
turned into werewolves as a form of
punishment if you behave like a beast
then the God would use lycanthropy to
turn you into one when lycanthropy was
used as a punishment the transformation
was almost always permanent though there
are stories where the offender was
turned into a wolf for a number of years
usually 7 or 9 and once they had done
their time they turned back into a human
and the curse was lifted in Norse and
Germanic folklore becoming a werewolf is
not seen as a punishment it's more of a
gift granting you increased strength and
speed these stories describe a belt made
from the skin of a wolf that allows the
wearer to become one in these depictions
the transformation is voluntary and not
determined by the phase of the moon but
if the belt is destroyed the ability to
transform disappears
there are other folktales were becoming
a werewolf requires the removal of one's
clothing they can only return to the
human form once they put on the clothes
they were originally wearing a French
tale written in the 12th century
features a baron named bisque Lavery who
vanishes every week for several days no
one including his wife knows where he
goes he eventually tells his wife he's
secret but he is a well and that his
clothing is the secret to his
transformation terrified of what she's
just heard his wife consults with a
knight who she happens to be having an
affair with and the two decide to steal
the Barons clothes unable to transform
back into his human form the Baron does
not return his wife marries the knight
and together they live long happy lives
is probably what I would say if this
tale did not contain werewolves the
Baron eventually returns in his werewolf
form and upon seeing his wife he bites
her nose off she is later banished along
with the knight and their children a
curse to be born without noses these
depictions of werewolves are personally
my least favorite their reliance on
their clothes makes them feel weak and
vulnerable in modern depictions
lycanthropy is most commonly shared
through the bite of scratch of an
existing werewolf there is an endless
list of ways that one can become a
werewolf but a rather common trope that
is carried throughout their ages is that
committing an unspeakable act will curse
one with lycanthropy
the taking of an innocent life being the
most common there are also those who are
unlucky enough to be born a werewolf if
we take a look at terry pratchett's book
series Discworld we can see that
werewolves are shown to be their own
race much like goblins and Dewar's
how was I to know the city watches
finest sergeant was aware the full moon
being required for a werewolf to
transform is something that we see a lot
less nowadays as it's become pretty
common for werewolves to transform when
and where they please the transformation
process itself has changed drastically
throughout the years from not being
mentioned much in early literature to
the spectacle it's now become in modern
film and television the transformation
appears in great detail and is almost
always depicted as being extremely
painful we see bones elongates and
change shape skin ruptures and tears and
the transformation can last for several
minutes and sometimes you just grow some
facial hair got a loved Teen Wolf right
the results of the transformation have
varied throughout the years with the
more traditional half-man half-wolf
appearance being replaced by the
enormous monsters that we have become
accustomed to see in today but why
exactly are the movies choosing to
dismiss the human element to the
werewolf in favor of the savage beast I
think for the most part this just boils
down to the fact that they can because
of the evolution of special effects it's
much easier to show a gruesome and
convincing transformation and through
CGI the werewolf can be shown as this
large terrifying monster sometimes
you're left of a confusing mix of both
monster and man
[Music]
maintaining some of their human features
when they transform makes it much easier
for us as the audience to be able to
relate to the werewolf as we can see the
conflict between their humanity and the
primal instinct of the wolf we often see
werewolves who struggle to accept or
even control their lycanthropy and it's
because of this redeeming feature that
the audience feels compassion towards
them on the other hand you have
franchises like underworld where it's an
all-out war between werewolves and
vampires and you have these huge hulking
alpha wolves which we have no attachment
to whatsoever but it works perfectly
fine in their universe so we've
established that the appearance of the
werewolf depends on context and despite
which one you may prefer you can argue
that they all have their place except
these ones so how does one end the
werewolf curse the simplest way to end
the curse is to die the only downside to
this option of course is that you're
dead which kind of sucks I guess there
are those who believe that a potion made
from Wolfsbane can kill lycanthropy
but Wolfsbane is also poisonous to
werewolves so take too much and you're
dead which we've really established as
bad calling a werewolf by their birth
name while they're a wolf can't cure
them this is personally my least
favorite of all the cures as it just
seems way too easy much more believable
cure for someone who's been turned is to
kill the werewolf that turned them there
are also many people who just believe
there is no cure
so this leads us into the methods of
killing a werewolf surprisingly enough
things that were killing human will also
kill a werewolf the problem lies we've
been getting close enough to do so
werewolves able to regenerate so if you
do not kill them quickly it is unlikely
that you will kill them at all it is
widely believed that werewolves have a
strong aversion towards silver and the
silver bullet to the heart or removing
their head of a silver blade or kill
them we've already mentioned that
Wolfsbane is like poison to a werewolf
this serves as a good way to slow down
and immobilize a werewolf and in large
amounts or inject it directly into their
heart
Wolfsbane can kill a werewolf the
easiest way to kill a werewolf is to
find them when they're in a human form
as this is when they are at their most
vulnerable however we've where was being
able to transform whenever they please
this may not be the case anymore when a
werewolf does eventually die their
corpse will often return to their human
form so we've arrived at our final
question why are we're also popular sex
appeal yep I said it werewolves are
strong assertive rugged alpha male type
characters who we find attractive and
most men aspire to be a little bit more
like
it's not just mayor werewolves though
films like Ginger Snaps and blood and
chocolate feature female werewolf
characters who display the same
attractive qualities in modern-day
stories werewolves and vampires and
natural enemies the reasons for their
hatred vary but it does guarantee an
epic conflict between two of the night's
most deadly predators so those of you
who dislike vampires will probably like
werewolves and of course some people
just like big scary monsters myself
included
like every other popular monster the
werewolf represents more than just a
vicious beast that scares us where we
choose to suppress our darkest desires
the werewolf either embraces them or
struggles to fight them the concept that
we can relate to
they represent the hidden evil in a
person the idea that everyone has an
inner beast waitin to be unleashed if
you've enjoyed this video then please
consider leaving a thumbs up as it helps
promote the video and allows the channel
to grow if there's anything you'd like
to discuss or have any ideas for future
videos then please let me know in the
comment section as always I've been your
host mythology and folklore explained